contact de l'écriture, de la
plume de Marie-Claire.
- J'entends leur voix,
je vois leurs visages.
Je les ve par ses personnages,
Marie-Claire Blais est devenue
une légende de la littérature
québécoise.
MICHEL M- Marie-Claire Blais c't
fondateur, c'est un monument,
c'est immense.
AUDRÉE WILHELMY, écrivaine
principalement, c'est la qualité
littéraire, le travail de
la langue, l'extrême maîtrise...
- Ça me semblait une période
- Née à Québec en 1939,
Marie-Claire Blais a marqué
notre imaginaire collectif dès
l'âge de 20 ans avec un premier
Elle connait la consécration
en 1966 lorsqu'ell
le Prix Médicis pour son roman
intitulé "Une saison dans la vie
MARIE-CLAIRE BLAIS, romancière,
poète ege
- Je suis très proche de
"Une saison dans la vie
même... Ça pourrait se passer
en Chinel, partout.
J'y suis très sensible, même si.
- En soixante ans de carrière,
Marie-Claire Blais a écrit doése
et trente romans,
et "Visions d'Anna". Sa fresque
"Soif",  1995,
a été un tour de force.
KEVIN LAMBERT, écrivain
- C'est parce que c'est
re qui donre qui donre qui donrt
d'exister à beaucoup de monde.
C'est une oeuvre qui a écrit
qu'on appelle les marginaux, les
es. Elle les a écrits
avec tellement d'humanité,
avec tellement de générositéce,
puis une grande profondeurpoéti.
- Maintes fois récompensée,
l'écrivaine partag la Ville
de Key West, aux États-Unis.
Son oeuvre a toujours été
traversée par une compassion
pour lesREMBLAY, éREMBLAY, éREMn
et ami de Marie-Claire Blais
- Elle nous donnait l'impression
de vouloir sauver le monde
humain pn qui aimait l'être
humain, mais individuellement.
- On ne peut pas rester dans
cet état de violence et de..
- Dès l'annonce de son décès,
les hommages sont venus de
ministreministreministreministrr
ministre du Québec.
- Je pense qu'on va plus parler
de Marie-Claire Bl
- J'espe
l'occasion de ramener beaucoup
de ses oeuvres de l'avant. qui
travail humblement chez soi.ce e
infatiguable, Marie-Claire Blais
a écrit jusqu'à son dernierture
a été to et parce que
sa littérature nous remplissait
d'humanité, une phrase à la
- L'amour seul demeure.
Radio-Canada, Montréal.